-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-All right. Thank you very much.
No, really, I appreciate that.
I know why you're excited.
We're back on the air.
It's a new year.
It's a leap year.
Did you know that?
It's a leap year,
we get one extra day.
I thought-- I heard that today,
I thought, "Oh, that's great!"
Then I remembered,
"Oh, one more day
of Trump versus Biden.
Fuck, no."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Thanks, but no thanks.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Yeah, I guess that,
that race is kind of over.
Trump won big in Iowa.
They had the Iowa caucus--
They had it
on Martin Luther King Day.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
What better way
to honor Martin Luther King
than the Whitest state
in the nation,
voting for a guy
who's gonna take you back
to the 1950s.
-The-- This is--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Well, I mean...
(CHUCKLES) ...come on.
Well, you saw, uh,
Nikki Haley came in third,
you know, so... (LAUGHS)
...she's a... (LAUGHS)
-...history buff Nikki, uh...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
She said,
"This has never been
a racist country."
-Never?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I mean, we can argue--
Um, "Never," really?
I mean, this is someone
who goes by Nikki.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(LAUGHS)
Because she--
if used her real name,
no one in her party
would vote for her.
-But it's not... Uh...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
And, uh... the other
Indian-American in the race,
Vivek Ramaswamy, he dropped out.
Dropped out of the race
and admitted
he is Sasha Baron Cohen.
-So, that's--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-I thought that. (LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Right, he was
the youngest candidate at 38.
-Now, it's gonna be,
you know, 82 versus 78.
-(AUDIENCE CHUCKLING)
The oldest... The oldest
combined number of years
we've ever had running.
Well, though Trump
was bragging this week,
he said he feels
like a 35-year-old.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-He said this. (CHUCKLES)
He owes it
to his fitness routine.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES) Really.
He says, every morning
he does 100 brain farts.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)